yeah welcome to yet another blitz game
must a couple of seconds because i had
the window screwed up ok so here we go
caro-kann i recommended the c5 move in
my video series but I must admit I've in
my video series for icc in german
language but i must admit that i have
forgotten most of it yeah at some french
type position alright yeah I got this I
got this recently in another game and
wasn't so bad Quincy for but admittedly
I really forgot what how displayed hmm
yeah I don't know
should I play Queen 85 or is it term is
it bad
at age 67 is also possible to you ok
Bella I need to be cautious he admitted
not familiar with the position also note
on a positive note here my rating to 488
this is a record for this account the
highest ever rating with the with the
comments I had higher ratings with other
accounts but this is the record form the
chess explained account and most of the
games played on this account are really
with with commentary I once in a while I
do those warm up games two to adjust and
okay this means there are some games
that are not with comments but it's not
the begin flows mostly those warm of
scale warmups games I don't score well I
need a couple of games to to adjust
somehow okay so what's this I've got a
really damaged pawn structure I never
pawned down but it looks like i have
decent chances to get e 5 or c5 bag wow
what a move
yeah well Queen g5 threatening on g2 and
Quincy one check isn't this good and
maybe go crack and no 92 we are he can
he can play this is so not bad it's not
brilliant for what I can take g2 but I
expected more
my 92 seems to be here seems to be the
only move basically what else rg3 Quincy
one maybe you can somehow play this but
it looks terrible now in me Moscow 92
but i wanna spend so much time what is
do I have something great on this one
what Quincy one what's the what's the
big can't hear there is no big point I
can catch just grab all this just like I
planned the others Bishop c5 with the
temple coming so we should see if I am
and now I'm a porn up not to point down
I did some really good position
gate doesn't have a decent movie queen
where exactly to g4 I can just go should
be seven yeah let's go fishin two sevens
yeah this is good I thought I threatened
something here but probably it's not so
terrible okay now he is intending look
see one of course so maybe should I take
on p2
take on b2b one adds not it's not
necessary why why engage in those
complications let's just drop the
neither the bishop back so look see one
I have it doesn't hang after oxy one
95 or something was possible maybe I
want to somewhat easier to play position
this looks are simple and good and how
do i take interesting Bishop Bishop
let's take this way this is where I can
place you five ok doesn't need to do
need to ok or even short castle and f6
yep why not actually
yeah he wants to wants to get to 2 g-3
yeah but after we have and and and so on
I take him
I take on e5 and Tarquin f6e emphasis
this is simple I'm good I think check
it's got the problem jack keeping all
this 505 is the key move which should
should be should be fine okay if I go I
don't want to be four yeah maybe just
threaten default is better
check the ship at five
Bishop f5 yeah it's not winning
instantly
at least I don't see of kids win again
simply Roxy to his checkmate checkmate
this took a while okay oh yeah yet
another win here on top of my rating
records so two points short of 2,500 now
all right yeah i think it was so it was
pretty good somehow but of course
they're after Queen g5 King f1 was was
really a strange move he needs to need
to go 92 so quickly greedy for already
was so so probably but 92 seems seems
okay I can take now if I want something
like this I this is this is just just a
messy position I don't know yeah thanks
for watching